we'll express anything any dissent from
the prevailing Fairtrade coffee shop
view on television and the left will try
to shut you down trust me we've lived it
if you do it in real life they may
physically attack you and then call
themselves at victims Hayden Williams
learned that lesson the hard way last
month he was attacked while trying to
recruit conservatives at UC Berkeley
yesterday his attackers a parent's
attacker Zachary Greenberg pleaded not
guilty to three felonies in the incident
Larry elder is a longtime Californian
one of the smartest and a radio show
host and he joins us today Larry thanks
a lot for coming on so I saw this story
my first thought was since you've been
there I think your whole life could you
wear a Donald Trump hat or shirt and
walk into Griffith Park in Los Angeles
how would you wouldn't it that it
wouldn't be advisable and I live on the
west side of Los Angeles and I wouldn't
think about wearing a mega cap anywhere
like like Santa Monica you're really
literally asking for somebody to hit you
in the face it's not just about hats
it's about bumper stickers during the
2016 election put up put a Donald Trump
bumper sticker on your car drive it
somewhere on the westside Park it I
leave it for a few hours come back and
see what happens
I had a show where I asked people to
call in and ask whether or not your car
had been defaced and whether or not you
had a Hillary sticker or a Trump sticker
and everybody who called up who made
made a complaint I had a trump sticker
not a single person who had a Hillary
sticker reported that he or she had his
or her card two-faced it's a very
serious kind of thing these people
believe that the other side a Tucker is
not just wrong they believe the other
side is bad is evil that way they can
justify taking these kinds of physical
actions the good news though about the
UC Berkeley thing is the guy who did the
assault the perp turned out not to be a
student and it turns out the UC Berkeley
police assistant and ultimately getting
this guy arrested good for them have you
seen anybody since since clearly we're
in the middle of a moment but moments
change but we're in a moment where one
side is not allowed to express his
political views in public for fear of
facing violence at least in the coastal
cities have you heard any liberals say
wait a second if we're punching Trump
supporters maybe someone will punch us
at some point means anybody he said
maybe this is a bad idea I don't think
so you saw what happened after Donald
Trump got elected in November of 2016
the the academia around this country
went absolutely crazy there was a
professor here who liked
Trump supporters to terrorists I mean
it's it's insane
and you look at the imbalance in terms
of registration whether they're democrat
or republican you're looking at
departments of poli-sci where twenty or
thirty professors are there one might be
registered as a Republican
no sociologist registered as a
Republican nobody in women's studies
were registered as a Republican now if
you're assuming that education has some
sort of impact on how people think in
reason then you have to conclude that
the more likely you go to college if you
major in humanities and most people do
the more likely you're going to come out
left-wing that's why I took her the
Democrats want to give you tuition free
college if you were likely to come out
Republican we wouldn't be having this
conversation why would you ever send a
child to college I mean I I have I'm in
the process of doing it it kills me I
mean at what point are people gonna say
this is poisoning our kids it's actually
killing some of them and it's wrecking
the country we're opting out how far
away is that point it's gonna take the
Alumni to do something about it because
the colleges of course depend on
contributions from the alumni and when
they understand and realize that their
kids are not getting an education
they're getting an indoctrination then
maybe then things will change but until
then nothing's gonna change no it's not
an impressive system and we need to be
honest about that Larry elder is great
to see you it always is my pleasure